it has been often said that dog is man's
best friend and obviously that isn't
just exclusive to men ask any pet owner
whether they own a dog cat rabbit
hamster or soul-sucking interdimensional
parasitic monster with too many
tentacles and they'll all tell you the
same your pet can be your best friend
they can give you the most unconditional
affectionate form of love possible and
as long as you treat your little buddy
right they'll be loyal to you for the
rest of your life and theirs it's not
uncommon for a pet to outlive their
owner especially if they belong to
someone who's elderly and that might be
a sad thing to think about for some
although it is important to remember the
positives like how much happiness and
companionship that animal would have
brought an aging owner in their last
years of life even someone younger who
dies unexpectedly might have had their
quality of life infinitely improved by
owning a loving pet to make them smile
but on the other hand there's the
negative downside that now some pets
have to live on after a tragic death not
fully understanding where their beloved
owner went so often we hear stories of
dogs that waited for their master to
come home only for them to never walk
through the front door again and it's
equally hard when things pan out the
opposite way and an owner loses their
pet the one silver lining is that we as
human beings have a far greater
understanding of death and the grief it
causes we know that eventually despite
how hard it can be to adjust to that
initial heartbreaking loss it is
possible to move on and for things to
one day get better but what happens when
someone can't accept the death of their
beloved animal companion when the
unconditional love of their pet is
suddenly missing from their life how far
will a person go to recapture that
feeling how long does it take for grief
born out of love to become an unhealthy
fixation and what is the true price of
obsession well the answer involves
scp-589 both what it can give and just
as easily take away for as long as she
could remember and even further back
than that aaron and her dog pancho had
been inseparable ever since her mom had
first adopted that scrappy little jack
russell terrier aaron had fallen head
over heels in love with that little
rascal loving a pet is different from
loving another person because they just
can't help showing how much they love
you back humans for all their good
qualities are so nuanced and not
everyone is honest with each other all
of the time but a pet especially a dog
even though they can't speak a bark or a
whimper or excited wagging of a tail can
easily tell you how they're feeling and
pancho was no exception aaron and her
mom cleo lived alone it was just the two
of them for quite a long time and while
cleo had little problem with that she
couldn't help but notice how isolating
it was for her daughter from a young age
aaron had always been quiet kept to
herself at school her mom kept expecting
her to make some friends asked to invite
them over or vice versa but it didn't
seem to be happening it didn't seem to
be bothering her daughter but cleo was
worried that it was giving her the wrong
idea
that being on her own was somehow better
so in an effort to give aaron at least
one source of companionship pancho
joined the family brown patches dotted
over his white fur he was the perfect
pet an excitable and loving little puppy
that aaron was immediately smitten with
when cleo told her he was hers to keep
being only seven years old erin broke
down crying with tears of joy her mom
had let her pick out a name for him and
she'd quickly settled on pancho at first
aaron had men to say it differently in
order to name the pup after a friendly
character from her favorite animated
movie but had mispronounced it in her
excitement at meeting the energetic dog
for the first time the name quickly
stuck though and as the years went on
and pancho got bigger aaron bought her
four-legged best friend a little poncho
of his own to wear when it started
raining over the following years pancho
became aaron's most constant and loving
companion even as she grew up moving
through her childhood and found making
friends a little easier with every
passing year there never came a time
when she didn't need her best friend
when erin had her first breakup in high
school and came home with floods of
tears in her eyes pancho could sense she
was upset and came wandering up to her
sitting in her lap to make her feel just
a little bit better then a few years
later when her mom got sick aaron had to
take care of her a task that would have
been much harder without pancho there to
alleviate that stress and lift her and
cleo's spirits and when cleo eventually
passed the little white and brown dog
sat quietly with his owner as she said
goodbye to her mom now that it was just
the two of them aaron and pancho were
living in a tiny apartment it was
cramped for one person and a dog but
aaron was just grateful to have a place
to live and the company of her favorite
pop besides pancho wasn't a puppy
anymore in fact he hadn't raced around
the park or chased a ball for quite a
long time with the numerous stresses of
her everyday life least of all holding
down two jobs in her desperate attempts
to make enough money to pay rent aaron
had hardly noticed the signs pancho was
showing his age it had been happening
gradually in the background over the
years he wouldn't chase the ball or
really move around much and when he did
it was little more than a lethargic plot
around the apartment perhaps it was
because of such a measured slower pace
change that aaron was unable to
acknowledge it she could see her old
friend was getting more tired sleeping
longer his tail rarely wagging as much
as it used to but by now that felt like
pancho's normal behavior then again
given how important her dog was to her
it's just as likely she didn't want to
accept the truth that unfortunately
nothing lasts forever he was almost 15
in human years which by all accounts is
an impressive age for a dog especially
one of pancho's size and breed it was on
a day that aaron was out working her
morning job when it happened the
faithful adoring jack russell terrier
who had spent his years being nothing
but loved and giving back only more love
in return curled up on aaron's bed the
apartment was still silent not a sound
to be heard save for those last tired
few breaths laying there maybe the dog
wondered if he'd ever get to see his
friend again if she would make it back
from work and time he closed his little
brown eyes and peacefully drifted off
for one last sleep during the break
between her shifts after the end of the
one at her first job and before starting
her second aaron had just enough time to
get home usually she had just had enough
time to eat and get herself ready for
the changeover then quickly check on
pancho before having to dash back out
poking her head into the bedroom she saw
her dog laying right there on her bed
there was a stillness to him that
instantly made her stomach drop his ears
didn't move when she called his name he
didn't react when she stroked his fur he
was gone and the moment she realized it
aaron felt like her whole world had come
crashing down the loss of her oldest and
closest friend hurt almost as much as
losing her mom erin always felt that the
problem with funerals wasn't just how
sad they were or how it always seemed to
rain when she went to one instead it was
more that they could never properly sum
up just how much someone truly meant
nobody could ever condense the year's
worth of love and memories into a burial
and it was worse when losing a pet there
was no procession no wake nobody else
there just her and pancho saying goodbye
a final time eventually things got to be
too much the heartbreak of pancho's
death was another struggle in a lifetime
of lows that had all left their lasting
wounds on aaron that coupled with the
stress of trying to carry on with a busy
life barely able to keep herself afloat
in either of her jobs had pushed her to
the edge of a breakdown maybe that's
what summoned it perhaps something had
sensed all of aaron's mental anguish and
had come to seek her out it might have
been that her wishes for something some
little alleviation to all the pain and
stress were finally being granted or
maybe it was just a gift left by her
neighbor the sun had long since set when
aaron arrived back at her apartment
stepping over the envelopes that
littered her doormat a few with words
like overdue and urgent notice printed
on them in red ink passing through the
hallway aaron paused as she always did
hoping to hear the gentle patterning of
paws against the floor her therapist had
dissuaded her from doing that saying it
would only make moving on from losing
poncho worse she didn't care she wanted
her dog back and opening the door to her
bedroom it seemed like someone had been
listening sat on her bed was a stuffed
animal right in the spot where she'd
found her little friend on that horrible
day it had been made to look like a dog
specifically resembling a jack russell
terrier with brown patches over its
white fur the plushie was even wearing a
little rain poncho the side of it was
enough to cause aaron to break down in
tears weeping and heavy sobs as she
dashed across the bedroom to hold it in
her arms hugging it tightly her tears
seeped into the soft fur as she felt it
against her face she didn't even think
to question where it had even come from
all she wanted to do in that moment was
hold the stuffed animal close for the
first time in what felt like years a
feeling of relief washed over aaron it
was as if everything was melting away
the stress of work and the toll of her
tiring shifts gone all the pain from
losing cleo and pancho dissipated too in
fact it felt like she now had her
beloved dog back no it was better than
that it was almost as though everything
about pancho his energy his spirit the
way he made her feel so calm and loved
was all distilled into this stuffed
animal and now it would never grow old
never age and die causing her more pain
aaron gripped the soft toy tightly the
longer she held the hug for the more her
stress and sadness faded her face was
still wet with tears although her
sobbing had gradually become low gentle
chuckles soon giving way to a peel of
uncontrollable laughter rising in volume
it was as though she had taken something
and the very chemistry of her brain was
being altered but after so much hardship
it felt good to the point where she was
almost light-headed laying down on the
floor of her bedroom arms locked around
the plushie that reminded her so much of
pancho aaron continued softly giggling
to herself her entire body relaxed so
much so that every part of her felt like
warm butter as if she was about to start
melting through the floorboards although
she didn't know it or probably wouldn't
have even cared her dopamine levels were
spiking flooding her with the bodily
hormone that relieves stress and makes a
person feel good in fact right now she
was feeling better than she ever had
every day that followed aaron would come
home to her stuffed animal her pancho
too as she liked to think of it it
didn't bother her how child like anyone
else might find it for a grown woman to
rely so heavily on a plushie for comfort
at any rate it wasn't something she was
advertising to anyone else after every
shift at both of her jobs she'd race
back to her apartment right to poncho 2
and just sit there just basking in the
way it made her feel it was the most
all-encompassing sense of euphoria and
relief reducing her stress so much that
she felt like she was floating her body
lighter than air that feeling was all
that mattered to her some days she
wouldn't even eat poncho 2 was more
important to her than food gradually she
started to become addicted to that
feeling having to wait until the end of
her work shifts to feel that rush of
happy chemicals flood her brain was too
long of a delay she started to crave it
while working unable to focus feeling
erratic and restless without pancho too
of course she couldn't risk bringing it
to work with her what if someone took it
or she dropped it her boss might see her
with a stuffed animal at her desk and
fire her on the spot or think that she
was absolutely crazy the only safe place
for her source of relief was at home but
erin knew she needed something to bridge
the gap while she was working the only
substitute that worked was taking a
photo of poncho 2 on her phone then
blowing it up and printing off a copy
erin could carry it around portably
keeping it in her pocket and taking it
out to look at it every few minutes
while she worked the hit of positive
chemicals it gave her wasn't quite as
strong as getting to hold her stuffed
animal after all it was just a grainy
photo from her phone essentially acting
like a patch to tide her over until she
could get back home to the real thing
however it didn't take long for aaron to
start taking poncho with her anywhere
that wasn't work to the grocery store to
visit her mom and her dog and of course
to therapy i'm rather concerned about
this pattern of behavior aaron's
psychotherapist dr lee stated when her
patient explained what had been
happening sitting across on the opposite
side of her office on a leather couch
aaron had poncho 2 pressed tightly
against her i don't care she sighed her
brain already awash with hormones that
kept her calm i like how it makes me
feel so i don't care aaron look at
yourself dr lee urged you aren't
properly dealing with your grief it
seems to me you're channeling all your
desire for positive emotion into this
stuffed animal pancho too erin corrected
her without taking her eyes off the soft
brown and white dog and its little cloak
listen to me the therapist insisted
trying desperately to get through to her
pancho your dog your real dog is gone
you lost him six months ago and your mom
cleo she passed away too you have to
process and come to terms with those
things as sad as they might make you
feel that's how we move on but what
you're doing right now isn't healthy
aaron it's becoming an obsession turning
away aaron press pancho ii up against
her face i don't care she repeated by
now aaron had become fully dependent on
poncho 2. showing up late for both jobs
just so she could spend longer feeling
those endorphins and hormones that
hugging the stuffed animal seemed to
bring it didn't take long for her to
start skipping entire shifts for days at
a time and cancelling any and all other
plans just to sit at home basking in the
relief brought on by her apparent
obsession her apartment became a mess
untidied piles of mail by the front door
the walls plastered with hundreds of
photos of her stuffed animal fueling her
obsession her evening job was the first
to fire aaron citing her recent absences
as the grounds for her dismissal even
then she still didn't seem to care the
fact she might not be able to make rent
barely registered returning home after
her other job called her in to tell
aaron she would no longer be working
there either she instantly looked around
for poncho 2 but it was nowhere to be
found all the photos on the walls having
faded aaron checked her phone all the
original copies of the pictures were
gone too instantly racked with fear so
addicted to the plushie that she could
barely function without it she began
tearing her apartment to shreds looking
for it she wrenched cupboards off their
hinges and tipped over her refrigerator
flipping her mattress aaron sliced the
fabric open with a kitchen knife
searching high and low for pancho 2 but
unable to find it anywhere she became
frantic erratic pulling her hair out in
a fit of uncontrollable despair where
had it gone had someone stolen it dr lee
the paranoia had already set in
convincing aaron that her therapist must
have taken pancho too she was the only
other person who knew about it and had
been so critical of her using it to make
herself feel better marching into dr
lee's office utterly in rage beyond
reason all erin could think about was
getting her stuffed animal back no
matter what she had to do
the effect it had on her was so powerful
so potent and addictive that living
without it was worth anything
even another person's life
little did aaron realize as her hands
grew wetter coated with more of dr lee's
blood after every bludgeoning strike her
therapist had no idea where poncho 2 was
in fact she had nothing to do with it
vanishing in the first place it had
disappeared all on its own along with
all the photograph copies aaron had
printed arriving somewhere miles away
scp-589 was ready to begin the whole
cycle again on its next victim it would
take on whatever shape it needed to
appease the desires of the very next
person to find it preying on their
vulnerability and making them totally
dependent on it that was what it did
everywhere it went leeching off people
that it could easily manipulate its
presence and interaction would calm
scp-589's victims helping to alleviate
their stress or make them feel better
about their deepest insecurities before
long these helpless victims would be
able to think of nothing else feeling as
if they were unable to live without
their obsession doll and every time that
was when
scp-589 would make its cruelest move it
would vanish leaving its prey in a state
of intense withdrawal with a calming
influence of scp-589 absent from their
lives all of a sudden the infected
people would suffer from a variety of
potential psychological symptoms manic
depression psychosis uncontrollable
despair dementia or in aaron's case
paranoia and a heightened sense of
aggression that caused her to murder dr
lee that was one of the earliest in a
spate of similar incidents that had been
reported as scp-589 traveled from town
to town its influence spread leaving
entire populations dead in its wake all
the while the stuffed animal fed on the
mental anguish that it caused its
victims making them pay the ultimate
price for their obsession now go and
check out
scp-2295 the bear with a heart of
patchwork and
scp-6330 guardians of the innocent for
more stuffed animal related anomalies
contained by the scp foundation